Hi there.
So welcome to maps of meaning.
I'm,
I'm going to tell you a story to begin
with and then we'll take a break and
after the break then I'll give you more
details about the class structure.
If you want to know more about the class
structure,
all you have to do is go look at the
syllabus online.
If you type my name into Google,
you'll get my website and then all the
courses are listed there.
And then you just go to the course
website and it tells you everything you
need to know.
I'll give you just a brief overview for
now.
Um,
there's a main textbook which I presume
you may have already purchased and
perhaps not.
It's available at the bookstore.
And then there's some adjunct readings
that are listed on the website that are
scientific papers that serve as
appropriate additional background
material,
mostly concentrating on neuroscience
material.
Um,
and so that's the readings and the order
of the readings is also laid out on the
website.
Uh,
in terms of assignments,
there are three,
three,
three and a half in a sense.
But the first one is,
uh,
I've developed some writing exercises
over the last few years for students and
um,
they're on a website right now called
self authoring.com
which you don't have to worry about
because you have access to the programs
through this course website.
Um,
I'll tell you about the two writing,
personal writing essays first.
So there's a lot of evidence that has
accrued over the last 15 or 20 years.
Some of it stemming from the
psychoanalytic tradition that writing
about your life fundamentally has
extraordinary benefits.
I would say some of them are health
benefits because it,
it,
it seems that,
and this is something we'll cover to a
great degree in this course,
it seems that if there are elements in
your past that you haven't dealt with or
areas of uncertainty in your current
life or in your future considerations,
then you bury heavy stress load because
of that.
Uh,
your body really doesn't like
uncertainty that much.
And oddly enough,
there can be uncertainty still in the
past.
You know,
if things have happened to you that you
really don't understand your,
your,
your body and your brains seem to
respond to that as if it's an area of
dangerous territory that,
that that has the potential in some
sense to haunt you.
And one of the ways that your body seems
to respond to that is by producing high
levels of stress hormones like cortisol.
And the reason your body does that is
because the more dangerous you're
environment is,
the more you should be prepared to act
rapidly at any given moment.
And that's fine except that it's costly
from a psychophysiological perspective,
you know,
it's demanding,
it's physiologically demanding in what
that means.
Is that over any reasonable span of
time,
it actually hurts you.
Now.
So writing about your past,
especially about things that were
somewhat difficult and hard to
understand seems to,
well it seems to lower the degree to
which you're haunted by uncertainty and,
and then the,
so I have one assignment for you,
which is writing an autobiography and
there is a structured program online
that guides you through that.
And basically what it asks you to do is
to divide your life into seven epochs
stages and then to write about the what
you experienced during those epochs for
better or for worse,
and then to try to understand them and
to articulate them.
And partly I want you to do that because
I,
I think it's,
it's a thing that is good to do,
especially for people your age,
especially when you're stopped stopping
one thing which you are going to be
doing soon in starting another.
It's a good thing to get caught up.
The other reason I want you to do it
though is because this course deals with
narrative in the psychology of narrative
and the relationship between narrative
and your own personal experience.
And there's no reason not to utilize the
theoretical propositions that we're
going to walk through in a,
in a personal and practical sense at the
same time that you come to understand
them theoretically.
So,
so you'll be asked to do that.
It's actually the first assignment and
then that will be given two to three of
you.
Each person's essay will be given to
three classmates and they'll provide
feedback on it.
So what I usually recommend is that you
write the autobiography for yourself.
The program will provide you with a
complete printout.
Then you can edit it,
you know,
because there may be things that you
want to write about that you don't want
anybody to read.
Now part of the reason I instituted this
was because it's impossible for the tas
to grade and assess that many
assignments because there's three
assignments and I don't know how many
people are in the class.
Probably somewhere between 60 and 80,
which I guess would be 70.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
And that's 210 assignments.
Like that's just not going to happen.
So,
and I didn't want to cut the writing out
of the class because I think it's
foolish to do that.
So we use a peer grading system and the
way that works is that you get your,
you get feedback from three peers and
you get the average of the best two
grades.
And then you're also marked on the
feedback that you provide.
Now what's happened in the past,
although this wasn't something I
expected,
is that students have actually found it
extremely useful to read the
autobiographical essays of their peers.
Because you know you don't really know
that much about other people and you
don't know how how similar you are to
the more how different you are from
them.
And that's especially true if you're
relatively young and having the
opportunity to read the kind of writing
that you're going to do that's being
produced by other people turns out to be
something that everyone has found
extraordinarily useful.
And I,
I'd like to take credit for that but I'm
not going to because I didn't really
realize that it would be so useful.
And what we're actually going to do in
further developments of the program is
set it up so that because people do use
this on a private basis and we're using
it in various places,
which I'll talk about in a minute,
I want to set it up so that when people
use it,
they can post their final product online
and have people comment on it and then
have the comments voted up or down.
You know,
so I,
so I'm trying to,
I'm thinking about are planning to
develop a site where people who are
interested in psychology could go and
practice their skills because it's very
useful for people to have feedback on
what they've written.
You know,
if it's constructive feedback and
constructive feedback should be
something like,
well,
you know,
I really didn't understand what you
meant here and this seemed kind of vague
and you know,
I really liked what you did here.
I think it's clear,
I understand what you're doing.
It seems to be well articulated and
delineated.
And so that's the next stage of the
project and that'll be coming along
relatively soon.
But anyways,
for now,
you'll start with the autobiography.
And I would recommend that you start it
now while like not this second because
here we are in this class,
but you know as soon as possible because
it's,
it's actually quite demanding.
And if you wait,
you'll find that you can't do it and
then you'll be annoyed.
And you know,
the whole purpose of the exercise will
be lost.
Plus it's also extremely useful to do it
over multiple occasions and sleep in
between writing sessions because the
evidence seems to suggest that if you're
doing autobiographical and exploratory
writing,
that you need the downtime to sleep in
order to consolidate the changes you're
making in your representational
structures.
And so doing it over multiple periods is
first of all,
um,
it's the only way really to do it
because it's too difficult to do it in
one sitting,
but it's also more beneficial.
Now,
one thing you might think about,
and,
and this,
this appears to be this situation,
is that your personalities actually
organized at the highest level of
analysis through articulation.
You know,
cause you're,
you're a,
you're a hierarchical
psychophysiological structure that
that's one way of looking at it.
And that that structure has to be
organized and unified because otherwise
you're like a little collection of
warring spirits and that's,
that's not an efficient and effective or
happy way live that involves a lot of
suffering.
And so the more you're able to
articulate yourself as an entity,
the more clearly defined you are.
And the more that,
the consequence of that clear definition
in unity is that you're not going to be
a house that's divided unto itself.
And that's,
and that's an extraordinarily useful
thing.
I mean,
one of the goals for most clinical
processes is the integration of the
personality,
right?
To make you an individual.
And an individual is something that's
not divided.
And the autobiographical exercise will
help with that.
And students have claimed in the past
and that they've been able to put a lot
of things that have been disturbing them
to rest as a consequence of writing
through it and thinking about it now,
you know,
there's nothing particularly magic about
writing,
but there is something magic about
thinking.
And there's something particularly magic
about thinking accurately and precisely
about important things,
you know,
and the re the advantage of doing that
through writing is that you can be much
more precise and accurate because you
get to externalize your thinking,
right?
Which is what you do when you write it
down.
And then you can think about what you
thought about so you can engage in a
recursive process that enables you to
sharpen up your words and sharpen up the
representations and extract out the
proper causal relationships that make up
your experience.
And you know,
the,
the point of memory,
people think,
well,
the point of memory is to remember the
past and that's complete rubbish.
That's not the point of memory at all.
The point of memory is to extract out
useful information from your experience
so you don't run into the same wall
repeatedly as you move through life.
And so if you know,
if you have things in your past that you
don't really comprehend and that are
still disturbing you,
what that means in some sense is that
there are areas of the world that you
don't comprehend well.
And that's not good because those areas
exist.
Even though you encountered them in the
past,
that doesn't mean they're gone.
And it,
it also means that there are places in
your past that are in some sense loaded
with information that you can extract.
And in some real way,
you make your psyche out of the
information that you extract from your
experience.
That's a kind of a Piagetian
presupposition.
I mean,
your,
your psyche,
your personality comes from somewhere.
It just doesn't observe.
You know,
we emerge out of nothing.
And so you can mine your past for
information that you have not completely
comprehended in,
in that way.
You can expand your personality and your
competence.
And,
and so I would also recommend,
and because this is also a motif of the
courses,
when you do the exercise,
like pay attention to your words because
you're using your words to construct
your personality.
You know,
and that's,
I mean,
one of the great discoveries in some
sense of,
of,
of human culture is that there's a
relationship between the word and the
construction of the world.
It's a,
it's a fundamental relationship.
You know,
and if you're precise and careful with
your words and with your writing,
then what you call into existence for
yourself as a well defined,
at sharply defined personality and a
sharply defined world.
And that's one in which you can,
you can act and,
and,
and obtain the consequences of those
actions that is necessary to sustain
you.
So I would say if you treat this
exercise like a class exercise,
then you're missing the point
completely.
It's not a class exercise.
It's,
it's something that's designed to bring
you up to date,
to free you from your past and to allow
you to move forward into the future.
Untrammeled by things that you might be
dragging behind you.
So you,
there,
there are instructions in the program
that tell you what state of mind to
place yourself into,
but,
but I'll,
I'll,
I'll describe it briefly.
Now you want to be in something that
that's like a reverie,
you know,
when a reverie is like,
it's,
it's a state of mind that allows you in
some sense to daydream.
You know,
sometimes when you're sitting and you're
not necessarily focused on anything,
which is increasingly rare these days,
your mind will wander,
you know,
and sometimes it wanders into the future
and sometimes it wanders around problems
that you have from day to day.
And sometimes it wanders into the past
to sort of circle around things that are
still consuming you.
And that's the state of mind you want to
be in.
So you can bring up to the surface
issues that are relevant and important
and then start to articulate them and to
address them.
You know,
as the relatively well educated adult
that you are now.
So and all,
sometimes people are hurt by past
experiences because they're too young
and too cognitively naive and
unsophisticated to actually understand
what's going on and to place it in a
broader context.
And the fact that you're,
you know,
you,
you become educated and that you're,
you're,
well mostly that you've become educated.
You might,
you may have the opportunity to re
reconstru and recast some of the things
that you've been thinking about,
you know,
and carrying along behind you.
So that's assignment one.
And I really would recommend get at it
because it's not something you can do in
the last moment.
Not without causing yourself misery and
grief.
The third assignment is it the same kind
of writing exercise except it's about
the future.
Now,
one of the propositions that this course
is predicated upon is the idea that
you're always in a cognitive schema that
contains at least two points of
reference and one is point a roughly
speaking in one is point b roughly
speaking.
And that your life is a continual
journey between point a and point b and
point a is the present as you construe
it and point b is the future that you're
heading to and in any moment you're,
you're,
you're operating with both those poles
active regardless of what you're doing
because you're a goal directed creature,
you're always aiming at something and in
order,
in order to obtain what you're aiming at
and in order to keep the structures that
you're using to organize your experience
functional and pristine,
you need to have a well defined sense of
where you are now and you need to have a
well defined sense of where you're going
in the future and why you're going
there.
Now this,
this exercise,
which is the third assignment,
asks you to put yourself in the same
state of mind that would be particularly
appropriate for the past offering
exercise,
except that you're projecting yourself
three to five years into the future.
Um,
that ability,
by the way,
probably only emerges at about the age
that all you guys are.
I've tried doing this exercise with high
school kids and it's,
they can't do it.
So we're making a high school version
where the kids have to think three to
six months into the future because that
seems to be really all they can manage,
you know?
Um,
so,
but you're at,
you're at a point where you know,
you can cast a future self farther out.
And so the idea is to put yourself in
to,
to adopt a particular attitude towards
yourself while you're writing the,
the,
while you're completing the access size.
And that attitude is imagine that you're
someone who's,
who's care you're charged with.
You know?
So what I really mean is to sort of
duplicate yourself and to take a
particular attitude towards your future
self.
And so the idea is if you were going to
construct a future for a person,
that person being you and the future was
optimized,
not in some,
you know,
moronic,
dreamlike manner,
that that involves yachts and,
and,
and supermodels.
Um,
but something that's realistic and
something that you can actually apply.
So if you were constructing the future
that would be best for you,
all things considered,
what would that look like?
And so the first part of the exercise
asks you to consider what I regard as
the basic,
the most fundamental dimensions of human
existence.
And you know,
those already.
What makes up life,
career,
family,
friends,
intimate relationships,
activities that you undertake on your
own time and concerns that are related
to health,
including use of drugs and alcohol.
So those aren't the only dimensions but
their fundamental dimensions.
And so what I'm asking you to do and
what the program will ask you to do is
to think,
okay,
if you could optimize your life along
all of those dimensions,
exactly what it would look like.
Because one thing you can be sure of is
that if you're not aiming at something,
you're not going to hit it.
The other thing you can be sure of is if
you're not aiming at something,
someone else will aim you at something
for some reason or some force that you
don't understand at all.
We'll aim you at something and you may
end up getting something you seriously
don't want and I would not recommend
that.
It's a stumbling through your life.
Aimlessly is not a good strategy.
You end up,
you could end up some terrible places,
but you will certainly end up as a pawn
of things that you may not want to be a
pawn of.
Now we've used this program,
we've tested this program quite
thoroughly so far.
We've used it for to begin with.
We used it for students at mcgill who
were struggling academically,
so you know there are smart kids,
but they were all,
they were on academic probation and they
filled out the future authoring program
and raise their grade.
Point average is 25% drop the dropout
rate by 30% and so,
which was quite stunning because it's
very difficult to improve people.
You know,
it's easy to make the mortars but it's
harder to make them better.
But then we've tested it now on more
than 3000 students at the Rotterdam
School of management.
And over four successive years we've
raised the performance of the students.
25% drop their dropout rate by 30% seems
to be in,
in the Rotterdam samples.
It was particularly effective for men,
but we don't know what conclusions to
draw from that because it was a
business,
it's business program and there was a
minority of women,
but they were outperforming the man.
And we don't know if that's a gender
thing or if the women who were in the
business program happened on average to
be more committed and more intelligent,
more conscientious than the men who were
in it.
But anyways,
the point is is that it will ask you to
consider those fundamental dimensions of
your life and to,
and to envision how they would be
constructed if you could construct them
properly.
And then it asks you to write for 20
minutes after you've done that,
about what your future could be like in
three to five years if it was optimally
structured free writing.
And then it asks you to do something
that's actually the reverse,
which is consider all your inadequacies
and weaknesses and stupidities and
foolishness and imagine what your life
would be like if you really let them
have the upper hand.
So,
and everybody I think has some sense of
that,
you know,
because everyone has some sense of how
they would go wrong if they were going
to go wrong.
And it's a,
it seems to me to be a very useful
exercise to allow yourself to envision
where you could end up if you didn't get
your act together and,
and,
and put things straight.
And to me in some sense,
what that means is that you're outlining
your own personal heaven,
then your own personal hell.
And it's useful to have both of those
because you can run away from what you
don't want and you can run towards what
you do want.
And that's quite motivating,
you know?
And one of the things I've observed
quite regularly in my clinical practice
is that people are often loath to make
decisions that will cause conflict.
You know,
so say,
especially if they're agreeable people,
you know,
say that you want to pursue a career
path that your parents don't agree with
and it would take a fair bit of,
you know,
intense negotiation in order to free
yourself up so that you could pursue
that path.
It may be just as easy to let it go from
moment to moment because that's conflict
free and end up doing something that
you're not committed to.
Then the question is,
then they'll,
where does that take you?
And if you have a very,
very clear idea of the kind of trouble
you can get into by facing the actual
realities of your life,
it makes you much more likely to fight
for what you need to fight for in the
present.
Because you know,
you know,
in some sense you're damned if you do
and you're damned if you don't.
So you might as well take the chance and
struggle for what you want now.
And so defining a negative future can
also be extremely useful.
So,
um,
plus it's,
you know,
it's,
it's realistic.
People's lives fall apart all the time.
It's uh,
you know,
you can expect that your life will fall
apart at some point in one way or
another.
So it's useful at least to prepare
yourself so that that doesn't happen any
more often than it has to.
And that if you're going to engage in
conflict and so forth in order to pursue
what you want,
that you have your rationale straight.
So the second part of the third part of
the exercise has you develop a fully
articulated rationale for your vision.
Now there's a bunch of reasons for that.
One is,
you know,
if you're having a discussion with
someone,
I can tell you how the typical
discussion about something important
goes.
If you're having a conflict with
someone,
it's usually someone close to you,
like person in your family,
you know,
you'll bring up something they don't
want to hear.
Okay.
So then they'll tell you two or three
reasons why that's actually your fault
and not theirs.
And if you can,
and sometimes that'll set you right back
on your heels.
It's the end of the discussion,
especially if they're quite emphatic and
maybe aggressive about it.
If you can get past that and engage in
the discussion and start to get
somewhere while then they'll usually get
angry at you and then past that they'll
cry.
And then past that you can have a
discussion.
But in order to get to the point where
you can actually have a discussion,
you have to have your arguments set up
like soldiers behind you.
And so if you,
if you want to move towards a particular
goal,
you're going to run into impediments.
And some of those impediments will be
other people and the voices in your own
head for that matter.
And the more deeply you have your
rationale for what you want articulated,
the more potent you are as a fighter for
your own destiny,
so to speak.
And so the third part of the exercise
asks you to think deeply about why it is
that the future you want is important
and not only to you,
because of course it's important that
it's important to you,
but also what effect moving towards the
future that you actually think would be
best for you,
what effect that would have on your
friends and your family and society at
large.
Because those things also have to be
taken into consideration when you're
constructing what you might regard as
your destiny.
And so these are very,
very important things to get right.
And one of the things that's really
remarkably pathological about our
current education system is that this
sort of thing isn't done more regularly
because I can't imagine,
since you know,
you're all university students,
there's absolutely nothing more
important than you can possibly do then
to spend some genuine time contemplating
who it is that you want to be as you
expand yourself throughout life.
You know,
there should be whole courses devoted to
that and there isn't.
And there's weird reasons for that,
which I'll get into later.
But this,
uh,
this,
it gives you an opportunity to thank all
right.
Maybe I could have what would be best
for me,
which by the way is different than what
I want.
Maybe I could have what would be best
for me if I knew what it was.
And I was actually aiming at it and my
experience has been like,
I've watched people for many,
many years in all sorts of different
situations and over very long periods of
time because I've had a clinical
practice for more than 20 years now.
And I can tell you that if you know what
you're aiming at,
there's a pretty decent chance you can
get it.
And if you don't know what you're aiming
at,
then God only knows where you're going
to end up.
And it will not be a happy place.
So it's very much useful to,
to put some thought into this and to,
to,
to consciously take hold of and
articulate what it is that you want for
a destiny.
And there's no reason to assume that you
can't achieve it.
You know,
you're all smart.
We wouldn't be here and you're all
reasonably hard working or maybe
extremely hardworking or you wouldn't be
here and a good chunk of your probably
creative.
So you know,
you have as good a chance of attaining
what it,
what you could be as anyone.
And so,
you know,
I would say dream realistically,
or maturely that would be a better way
of thinking about it.
But also don't be afraid to be ambitious
about what you want because you know the
world's full of possibility and there's
no necessary reason that you can't make
use of that possibility.
And I can tell you as well that you
better make use of it because although
I'm sure you know this to some degree,
um,
at some of you do anyways,
life hits you hard and tragically
multiple times throughout your
existence.
And no one escapes from that.
And so the problem with that,
apart from the fact that it's painful
and anxiety provoking and use,
that it can make you bitter.
And once you're bitter,
you're a dangerous person and,
and a miserable person.
And so the only way to protect yourself
against that happening is to have the
kind of life that's rich enough and
meaningful enough so that you're,
you can take the blows and accept it
because there's no way you can escape
from the blows there.
They are an inevitable part of life.
So your life better be rich enough so
that you think,
okay,
well on balance the price I paid for
being alive is worth it.
Um,
one of the things we're going to talk
about in depth in this class is the
social consequences of failing to do
that because bitter people are
extraordinary,
extraordinary dangerous from a
sociological and a political
perspective.
And so,
you know,
the,
the ranks of the,
of the totalitarians of the past are
full of people who are arrogant and
resentful and you know,
that the steps past arrogance and
resentment are,
you know,
murder and genocide.
And so,
you know,
the less of that,
the better.
So part of the utility and putting your
personal house in order is that you're
much less likely to be a pathological
force on the sociological and political
stage.
So,
as far as I'm concerned,
this is extremely important work and we
already know from the empirical
evidence,
strangely enough that it seems to have a
very profound effect on people.
So,
all right,
so the other assignment is,
uh,
an essay.
You can write an essay on your choice of
topic as long as the topic is related in
some intelligible way to the course
material,
which really leaves you quite a wide
range of choice.
And it can be a scientific essay,
it can be a philosophical essay,
and it can also be a creative project if
you want to do that.
Although if you choose to do a creative
project,
then you have to write a commentary on
it.
So,
so in some sense you have the
opportunity to engage in whatever
project you'd like to engage in.
As long as,
as I said,
it has some relevance to the class.
So there was those three assignments,
there's the readings,
and then there's a final exam at the
very end.
And the final exam is multiple choice,
strangely enough.
But it's the stick that goes along with
the carrots,
you know,
because one of the things I've observed
in the class is the reading is difficult
and you actually don't have to do it to
participate in the class.
And so of course people don't do it
because,
not because they're,
while sometimes because they're lazy and
useless,
but mostly because they prioritize
their,
their time because their time demands
are heavy and things that aren't
absolutely crucial don't get done.
So the exam makes it crucial.
So if you do the reading you,
you won't have any trouble with the
exam.
But if you don't do the reading,
then you will have trouble with the
exam.
So I would say do the reading and stay
caught up because it'll make the course
richer experience and plus he'll do
better on the final exam.
So,
so that's basically the outline of the
course.
Now what I'm going to do is walk you
through the material fundamentally and
try to explain more deeply why it's
relevant.
And one of my aims in this class,
it's like I'm not a fan of,
of information for information sake.
I think that it's a mistake to pursue
information that isn't relevant.
I mean,
you can pursue it.
If you think it might become relevant in
the future,
that's fine.
You know,
that's a calculated risk.
But I don't want to teach you anything
in this class that you don't find
immediately compelling and useful both
personally and on the broader social
stage.
And I think the information that I'm
going to provide to you,
um,
I think it's absolutely vital.
I do.
I truly do not believe that you can live
properly without knowing what I'm going
to tell you.
And you know,
that's kind of,
you might think that's kind of a
grandiose claim,
but I'm also not trying to take credit
for the content of the information that
I want to purvey.
You know,
I've spent a long time analyzing,
analyzing the,
the,
the fundamental elements of the great
stories of the past.
And people are historical creatures and
unless they're grounded in the past,
unless they're grounded in history,
they float up and disappear and it's not
good.
And so you need to know,
and especially modern people,
modern people have to understand to
believe.
And maybe that's fine,
who knows?
But we paid a big price for it because
our,
our demand to understand has made it
difficult for us to have any faith in
the sorts of things that human beings
have believed throughout the entire
course of history.
And that makes modern people in some
sense educated but bereft or
philosophically week.
And they're often nihilistic or
ideologically possessed in either of
those two things is those are like
mental illnesses as far as I'm
concerned.
So I also believe that the material in
the course serves as a vaccination
against ideological possession.
And I think that ideological possession,
what was certainly the social
psychopathology that threatened the
world most in the 20th century,
it'd be nice if we could rid ourselves
of the tendency to adopt mindless single
cause explanations for things and
confused that with actual education and
wisdom.
So I want to outline to some degree what
I think it he ologies are and why
they're so pernicious and also to
provide you with what I think of as an
alternative to ideological thinking
that's still grounded in what's grounded
in meaning fundamentally.
No.
So,
so anyways,
I thought I was going to tell you that
after the break,
but I guess that didn't happen.
So,
um,
do you have any questions about that to
begin with?
I cause then I want to tell you this
story.
Yes.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Yeah,
be do it's available now.
All you have to do is go online and you
can sign up for the,
for the,
for the writing assignments you have to
generate a username and password.
But that's,
if it isn't functional,
let me know.
I last time I checked that it was
functional in it,
you know,
it's,
it's pretty reliable.
So,
um,
you can start,
you can start right away.
You just find the website and the way
you go.
Anything else?
So,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
the next time you have a really intense
discussion with someone about something
that's important and just watch what
happens if you don't quit,
you know,
and you will quit if you're not grounded
in what you say firmly and you've
thought it through like mad,
like what right.
Do you have to impose any suffering on
someone to make a point?
If you don't know what you're talking
about,
you have no right at all.
So,
and you know there's lots of times when
you're dealing with people in intimate
relationships where you have a conflict
of viewpoint and interest and you know
you can either ignore that,
which means you sweep it under the rug,
which is a very thing to do
or you can fight it through and to fight
it through means that you're going to
cause emotional upset in the present.
And people shy away from that and
rightly so,
you know,
because it can get out of hand.
But the problem was shying away from it
is that it's a small problem right now.
If your eyes are open,
you can see that it's going to develop
into a large problem in the future.
If you address it now,
it's going to cause conflict,
but it's nothing like the complete hell
that it'll generate if you let it go.
But then you have to fortify yourself
property to engage in that kind of
battle.
And you know,
these sorts of battles that will take
place throughout your whole life.
If you want to make,
if you want to have a raise for example,
or if you want to deal with a bully at
work,
or if you,
you know,
any time that your autonomy or your
freedom is challenged or that your sense
of moral propriety is challenged so that
people are trying to get you to do,
say something that you believe to be
wrong.
If you're not fortified with,
with arguments like,
like a general in charge of soldiers,
you're just going to get walked all
over.
And that's not a good thing.
You know,
it's to be a helpless victim is a bad
destiny and it's,
it's certainly pollutes your psyche to
also be in that situation.
So you want to make yourself into
something that's formidable.
And the way to do that in a civilized
society is to make yourself a master of
words.
And,
and,
and in the philosophical sense and words
that have meaning and that you're
behind,
that you're willing to stand for.
And so that it's not the same as say
trying to win an argument.
I mean,
if you're smart and you're dealing with
someone that you have an intimate
relationship with,
you never tried to win the argument.
It's like what the Hell is good?
Is that going to do you still have to
live with the person,
you know,
they'll just take their revenge on you
some way if you win.
So what you want to do is solve the damn
problem,
but that usually takes a bit of a war.
So,
and then you better be ready for a war.
You're going to be the loser and maybe
you're the person you're fighting with
will be the loser too.
So,
all right,
I want to tell you a story and there's a
bunch of reasons I want to tell you this
story and one is,
is because the story illustrates very
well how unbelievably profound
archetipal revelations manifest
themselves in very,
very simple form.
Because I'm going to read you a story
that's written for four year olds and
it's a variant of the oldest story that
humanity has ever told.
And we know that we know what the oldest
writings are that we've been able to
dredge up and translate.
And this is a variant of a story called
the,
I don't know how to pronounce this
property.
Um,
the Enuma elish which was a Sumerian
story from thousands of years ago that
that's actually quite nicely documented.
We have the tablets and so forth and
they were discovered in the late 18
hundreds but it's a,
it's a very intimate hero's story as
well.
And the hero stories are the story of
human beings.
Fundamentally a hero myth is the story
of the,
of the individual in society.
And so the reason that hero mythology
for example is so absolutely potent is
because it provides the grammatical
structure for,
for,
for understanding your life and laying
it out in the world.
And so this is a small variant of that
and it,
it's,
it'll give you an idea as we walked
through it,
how this sort of information is
transmitted.
It'll give you some indication of how it
is that you understand such information
even though you don't know that you
understand it.
Because this story obviously is about
something completely fictional.
One fantastic,
right?
It's,
as you can tell,
it's a story about a dragon.
And of course,
I mean,
how many of you have watched a movie
about a dragon in the last year?
Okay.
Yeah.
Is there anybody who hasn't?
Okay.
You haven't,
you haven't.
That's good.
That's amazing that you could actually
avoid that.
So,
and also,
so,
you know,
that's kind of strange because of course
those things don't exist.
And so you might ask yourself what,
what accounts for their absolutely
enduring popularity and even their coat
like popularity.
Cause you see that with,
with,
um,
both in Harry Potter because there's a
dragon in here,
multiple dragons and Harry Potter,
right?
In the second volume,
there's the basilisk that lives
underneath the school,
which is a very,
it's a very archetypal idea.
And then of course there's the harbor
and then there's how to train your
dragon.
And it's like there's dragons in
sleeping beauty and like there's dragons
everywhere.
And of course that's why this boy has
this problem is that he sees them
everywhere and people say,
well,
there's no such thing.
So.
Okay.
So,
so we're going to walk through this and
I'm going to explain to you some of what
it means.
So the first thing that's kind of
interesting about this illustration,
and I don't know if the author Jack
can't or the illustrator knew this,
but if you look at traditional
representations of this figure called a
neuro burroughs,
which is a,
like in a world in circling serpent,
it's very,
very frequent that the thing,
the,
the entity has a twist and its tail.
And from what I've been able to
understand,
that twist represents infinity.
So the dragon in part is something that
represents what's beat,
what's continually beyond our realm of
knowledge.
And so it's a very complicated idea.
And an echo is everywhere.
So,
so one thing you can think of is that
there's always something that's beyond
your realm of knowledge,
your realm of competence and ability.
And another thing that you can think of
is that people have known this for a
long time and it's,
it's a strange form of knowledge because
it's knowledge about the limits of
knowledge.
So it's like Meta knowledge and,
and you can generalize from that Matt
and knowledge to some degree because you
can say,
well as you go through your life,
you're going to have a lot of problems.
And then you could also say as you go
through your life,
a lot of unexpected things will happen
to you and many of them will be
problems.
And then you can say,
well,
what that means is that you can
conceptualize a class of unexpected
things,
right?
The class of unexpected things is all
the potential unexpected things that
might happen to you.
And then you could say,
well,
how do I deal with an unexpected
thing?
And the answer to that is you learn how
as you deal with it,
but you could also ask yourself,
well,
how do I deal with the class of all
unexpected things?
And that's a whole different question.
And I would say in some sense that's a
primary religious question.
It deals with the fundamental realities
of,
of life.
There are things outside your domain of
competence outside of the domain of
competence of your culture.
And you will have to deal with them.
So how do you deal with them one by one
or can you deal with them as a class?
And so one of the things that I would
like to,
um,
offer you as a hypothesis is that
figures like the dragon are symbolic
representations of the class of all
things that lie outside of your
competence.
Now you see the figure of the serpent or
the dragon in,
in relationship to a dwelling in very
many stories.
So one story for example,
that this motif comes up in is the story
in Genesis,
the story of Adam and Eve because
there's a serpent in the garden and
that's exactly the same idea as the
dragon in the house.
And that's the same idea as the fact
that no matter how hard you try to make
the environment that you're in stable
and secure the things that you don't
understand and don't know how to deal
with her going to poke their head inside
and,
and emerge.
There's no way of keeping so to speak.
There's no way of keeping the snakes out
of the garden.
So it's a,
it's the wrong approach.
You know,
maybe you could build a fence that's 200
feet high and that's drilled a hundred
feet into the ground that's made out of
solid concrete and put a cap on it and
sit in the middle of that and not let
anything in,
in first of all,
that seems like a bad strategy,
but even not,
it doesn't matter because the things
that you don't understand can emerge
inside of you as well.
And that happens for example,
every time you get sick or every time
your body does something that you don't
expect or want it to is there's no
escape from this situation.
And that's partly what this story is
about.
So this little boy,
you know,
he's,
he's maturing,
he's growing up,
he's becoming self conscious and he's at
an age because he's about three or four,
he's,
he's at an age where selfconsciousness
actually seems to emerge in children
where they become aware of themselves as
really separate creatures and often
start to concern themselves with
covering up,
putting clothes on,
not being naked around other people,
you know,
and some children care about that and
some don't.
But,
but that is the age approximately that
it develops.
You know,
so,
so this boy,
he's in his house,
he's in his window and he's become aware
of something that's at least perplexing.
Now,
you know,
you might say,
well given the size of the dragon that
it's also terrifying,
but we'll start with perplexing.
So because what's perplexing can turn
into what's terrifying if you ignore it.
So,
and that's partly what this book is
trying to present.
It's funny cause it's a cute little
book,
you know,
it's,
it's just a cute little
book.
So,
so there he is.
What sort of facial expression is that?
What do you think?
Surprise.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what happens is,
well the kid wakes up,
do something on his bed.
Yeah.
He's not sure whether he should be
afraid.
We're interested.
So he sorta both.
He's,
it's like a,
it's like a startle response in some
sense,
but at least it's a focus.
It's a bit of focused attention.
He's discovered something.
Billy bixby
was rather surprised when he woke up one
morning and found a dragon in this room.
It was a small dragon about the size of
a kitten.
The dragon wagged it's tail happily when
billy padded padded it's head.
Okay,
so well what can we observe about that?
Well,
first of all,
something unexpected has happened,
right?
And for a little kid that's going to
capture their imagination,
it's like,
Whoa,
you know,
is that scary or,
or you know,
what's billy going to do?
And,
and it,
it said narrative hook,
something unexpected has happened.
All right,
but,
and it's paradoxical to a,
because it's a dragon and billy is
surprised,
but it's a small dragon.
It's only the size of a kitten.
And you know,
kittens book,
kids know about Kittens,
they're soft and cuddly and you know,
they've got claws,
but they're basically harmless and
interesting.
And not only that,
when billy interacts with the dragon at
this size,
it actually wags his tail and is happy.
So there's,
there's a paradoxical situation set up
for the boy right at the beginning of
the narrative,
which is something unexpected happens
and it has ambivalent significance.
So,
and he's interested in it and he's alert
to its possibilities.
But that's about as far as it goes.
So
really does what the logical child would
do.
It's called referencing by the way.
So for example,
if,
if there's a child in a room and I'm,
I was runs by the child,
will orient towards it,
follow it with,
with its size and its head.
And then if the parent is around,
then the child will reference the mother
or the father and read off the mother's
face what the significance of that event
was.
You know,
because it's,
it's,
it's unclassified significance
intrinsically interesting because it's
unexpected and fast enough to alert you
to produce an orienting response so that
you attend to it and that it demands
classification.
So it starts off interesting and even
potentially upsetting.
That's how it manifested itself to begin
with.
And then the referencing,
which is the,
the look at the mother's face allows the
child to utilize the wisdom of the
parent in order to rapidly classified
the significance of the event.
So then you think,
well,
you know,
the mother says,
oh well it's just a mouse.
We'll take care of it later.
That's one reaction.
The other reaction is,
you know,
she jumps up on the table and has a
screaming fit and then calls the
hospital could be cause she has a panic
attack.
It's like the meaning of the mouse under
those two circumstances is very much
different.
You know,
she could also say,
well there aren't any mice here,
which is also a rather pathological
response but perhaps not as bad as the
full fledged panic attack.
So I mean that's children.
The part of the point of that is that
when a child encounters something
unexpected,
so that's outside of their domain of
competence,
it does attract their interest,
the laureate towards it and explore it.
But then they'll use whatever cultural
information is that at hand to classify
the phenomena so they know what to do in
its presence from then on.
So that,
that's an interesting thing to think
about a,
because there's a couple of things that
you can think about.
A mouse.
One is what is a mouse,
not like a scientific question.
And the other is if there's a mouse,
what should you do?
And that's not a scientific question.
That's a moral question because it has
to do with behavior and when you're,
it turns out that when you're attempting
to classify a phenomena,
the way that you're set up,
given that you're a living creature and
that you're very much action predicated,
is that when you're trying to classify a
phenomena,
it's implication for behavior is more
important than its objective nature.
And so almost all the knowledge that you
have that grounds you in the world is
actually information about how to behave
in the presence of things.
It's not information about what they are
from an objective perspective and your
brain is set up that way,
then you're out.
You're very,
very much action oriented peak.
Well obviously because you inhabit a
body that moves and your primary problem
in life is what to do with your body as
you move through space and time.
And that's a particular category of
knowledge.
I would say that's the category that's
essentially moral and the the ideas that
underlie the essential categories of,
of action,
moral action,
our religious ideas,
or at least that's a claim.
So that puts them in a completely
different category than scientific
ideas.
And it also places them somewhere where
there's no necessary conflict between
the objective and uh,
and the behavioral.
You have to know how to behave and
science does not tell you that in fact
it can't.
There's the scientific method is
actually designed so that the
motivational significance of objects or
entities is stripped off them before the
investigation begins.
You have to treat the phenomena as if
it's objective and neutral
insignificance and that's fine,
but that doesn't mean that things are
objective and neutral insignificance.
It just means that for the sake of a
certain set of processes which are
basically associated with the scientific
method,
you have to undertake that operation
before you start the game.
And I think it's very pathological turn
in human history that we've confused the
necessity of stripping off the
significance from something before.
You can study it scientifically with the
idea that things have no significance
intrinsically because that's a
completely debatable point.
It's certainly not how your brain is set
up.
You know,
when you might think,
well your brain evolved while that's the
hypothesis.
Anyways,
and you might say,
well,
what did it evolve in relationship to?
And then you might say,
well,
it evolved in relationship to reality
because that's actually how you define
reality.
Especially if you're a Darwinian and the
way your brain reacts to things is that
it assesses their motivational
significance first.
So then you might say,
well,
how can you justify the claim that the
motivational significance isn't real?
And answer as far as I'm concerned is
you can't,
the motivational significance of
something might be the most real element
of it anyways.
And you certainly act like that even if
you don't believe it technically or or
rationally.
As you move yourself through the world,
you're constantly evaluating things for
their motivational significance.
And you do that without thinking.
It's just how you are.
So,
so that's also we're thinking about,
we'll return to that many times.
Billy,
he went downstairs to his tellers
mother,
there is no such thing as a dragon said
billy's mother.
And she said it like she meant it.
It's like,
well,
yes,
no.
So then you might say,
well you're,
you have a three year old child and they
have the man,
maybe they're having a hard time going
to sleep cause it's dark and fear of the
dark is actually an emergent phenomena.
So as the child's fear system develops,
as the child becomes more and more
ambulatory and needs to be protected
from the consequences of wandering off
unattended,
the fiercest does also come online.
And what do they do?
They populate the darkness with
monsters.
Now you might say you go into your
child's room and you might say,
and they say,
well,
you know there's a monster in the dark
and you say,
well,
there's no such thing as monsters.
And then you think really there's no
such thing as monsters.
You know?
That's why people are terrified to let
their children walk three blocks to
school because there's no such thing as
monsters.
It's like there are plenty of monsters
and you might say,
well there aren't monsters like dragons.
And then I might say,
well what makes you show so sure of
that?
Why is that a bad classification
heading?
You know,
if you're talking about the class of all
dangerous things that lurk in the
darkness,
let's say,
because that is a good place for the
class of all dangerous things to lurk.
How better to represent it than in
monstrous forum because the monstrous
form takes pieces from all of the
potential dangers and amalgamates them
into a single danger and says,
look out,
wander into the domains that you don't
understand at your apparel.
Well that's not fake.
It's not false.
It's real.
You know,
and children are small and edible and
they've been that way throughout
history.
And you know,
people who children who wandered too far
away from the campfire,
we're going to get hurt.
And so the idea that there are dragons,
for example,
there aren't monsters.
That's not a good idea.
It's not the right approach.
I remember once,
this may only seem peripherally related,
but it's actually,
it's an integrity related.
One time I remember my daughter when she
was about three or there about,
she came to talk to my wife and I in the
morning and she said she had a
nightmare.
And the nightmare was she'd seen this
clear stream running through,
it sounds like an environmentalist fairy
tale.
She saw this clear stream running
through a forest and there was garbage
in it.
And when she saw the garbage in it,
you know,
she was upset about it.
And then she came into our room and she
said that this was upsetting and that
why was their garbage in the stream?
And one response to that is,
you know,
don't worry about it.
It was just a dream.
And the other response is,
well,
what would you do if you came upon a
situation like that?
And so we asked her that and she said,
well,
maybe I could take the garbage out of
the stream.
And so I said,
well,
you just close your eyes and just
imagine that,
you know,
you take the garbage out of the stream
and maybe you go put it in the garbage
can and then that's the end of the
problem.
So she was quite happy with that.
And then she wandered off and went back
to sleep.
And that's,
that's a better answer than that was
just a dream,
you know.
And,
and I don't exactly know what you mean
when you say that was just a dream
anyway.
It's like,
what the hell do you know about dreams?
You know?
I mean,
really everything in the world emerges
as a dream and you don't understand
dreams at all.
You go to sleep and they happen to you.
You don't control them.
They're phenomena of nature.
So what are you going to say?
That was nothing.
It's like,
yeah,
sure.
It's not nothing.
Well,
that's her position.
Billy went downstairs to tell his mother
there's no such thing as a dragon,
said billy's mother,
and she said it like she meant it.
That's a person who does not want to
admit to the existence of chaos and
disorder or who wants to protect your
child from that.
And you know,
there's some utility in that because
there's children have a limited capacity
to deal with chaos and disorder,
but to deny its existence in their
presence is the wrong thing to do.
First of all,
you give them the wrong idea about the
nature of the world.
Second,
you're implicitly telling the child that
there are certain elements of reality
that they have that have to be hidden
from them because they're either so
overwhelming that no one can deal with
them or that the child is so useless
that the child can't deal with them.
That's not the right message to give
your children.
The right message is there are dragons,
but if you're careful,
you can learn how to deal with them and
we'll help.
So it's like Eda pulled mother mistake
number one.
Kelly went back to his room and began to
dress the dragon came close to billy and
wag its tail.
So it's looking for attention,
right?
There's something in the household
that's looking for attention and people
are ignoring it.
Now,
if I don't know how many households
you've walked into where that's the
case,
I mean,
I dunno,
it's endemic among households where
there's a number of things that are
demanding attention and no one's paying
attention to them.
There are things that you don't talk
about.
Are there things that you have to
pretend not to notice?
And everyone walks around on eggshells
or on the elephants underneath the
carpet pretending that everything's all
right and there's nothing that's all
right in the household at all.
And so people in this situation like
that or denying the reality of their
own,
not of their own senses,
but if something even deeper than that,
they're denying the reality of the
importance that their own nervous
systems are signaling to them
constantly.
It's something's up here.
Something's up here.
Something's not good.
It should be attended to.
It's like,
no,
everything's okay.
We don't talk about that sort of thing.
It's like,
that won't make it go away.
Billy went back to his room and began to
dress the dragon,
came close to billy and wagged it's
tail.
But Billy didn't pat it.
If there's no such thing as something,
it's silly to patted on its head.
It's reasonable proposition.
Billy washed his face and hands and went
down to breakfast.
The dragon went along.
It was almost,
it was bigger now,
almost the size of a dog.
Well,
so that's interesting.
So for some reason the dragon is now
growing now,
we don't really know why it's growing.
So that's another mystery that's popped
up in the middle of the narrative.
You know,
we might infer,
while we won't infer anything,
it's foreshadowing the fact that the
dragon is growing in the idea there,
there's something like a hint of an idea
that if something surprising attracts
your attention and you don't attend to
it,
then it has the probability of expanding
in size.
And that's a very interesting thing,
that idea.
So I can give you an example of how that
sort of thing can occur in your own life
and how your senses blind you to the
reality of things.
So let's say you get a bill from the tax
department and they say,
well,
you owe us $79 and 47 cents and so you
think,
well what is that?
Well that's a piece of paper.
That's what you have in front of you,
a piece of paper.
So you crumple it up and you throw it in
the garbage.
And so then a month later you get
another bill and it's like $95 and it's
a little bit more insistent.
And so you crumple that up and you throw
it in the garbage and you continue to do
this.
And what happens is that little thing
that you're ignoring is going to
aggregate
monstrous qualities across time.
And if you leave it long enough,
then it's going to be something that
you're really going to have to contend
with.
Like maybe it's something that destroys
your credit history so that you don't
get to have a mortgage on your house the
first time that you tried to buy a
house,
you know,
or maybe you get tangled up with the tax
department and they audit every income
tax return you do for the rest of your
life,
which would make you miserable for about
a month,
a year on a basis for the next 50 years.
So it's,
it's a strange thing because you know,
your,
your census seemed to be designed to
tell you what's immediately relevant in
this immediate space right now,
here and now.
And so you see things a certain way,
but they're not really that way and lots
of things that seem relatively innocuous
from an objective perspective have the
capability of manifesting themselves in
magnified proportions across time and
all you have to do in order to allow to
have that happen is just do nothing.
They'll grow of their own accord.
If you don't attend to them,
and pretty much all the real problems
that you'll face in your life are going
to be like that.
There'll be things in your
relationships,
for example,
that you think,
well,
I don't really have to attend to that.
It's like,
fine,
you know,
don't attend to it once you've been
alerted to its existence and see what
happens when that's what this book is
about,
so it's bigger now.
Both the size of a dog,
still not too bad.
It's a dog you could deal with that
probably barely sat down at the table.
The dragon sat down on the table.
This sort of thing was not usually
permitted,
but there wasn't much billy's mother
could do about it.
She'd already said there was no such
thing as a dragon.
And if there is no such thing,
you can't tell it to get down off the
table.
I like this scene for a variety of
reasons.
One of the reasons I like it is because
if you watch parents with their young
children,
one of the places that there's terrible
conflict around is eating.
Many children are somewhat neil phobic.
They don't like new things,
or at least they tell you that they
don't like them.
And many children are also quite
disagreeable,
you know,
so children vary in their temperament
and there are some children who will do
everything they possibly can to please
you.
And they're pretty,
you know,
they're easy children to take care of
all the,
they have their own sets of problems.
Um,
and then there are other children who
are very disagreeable and there are
fundamental proposition.
Position in life is no,
and that usually emerges at about the
age of two.
Right.
And that's when children discover no,
and it's the magic word,
you know,
because parents tell them that please
and thank you are the magic words.
And that's wrong.
No is the magic word.
Because what know is,
is a test case.
It's like,
all right,
where do I end and where do you begin?
And the way I discovered that as by you
asked me something,
I say,
no,
my son was like that.
He was,
he was hilarious as a two year old
because like everything you asked him
was no.
So I'd ask him a bunch of things that I
knew he didn't want to walk,
do you know?
And he'd say,
no,
no.
Then I'd say,
well,
how would you like some chocolate ice
cream?
And then he was really on the road by
then and he'd say,
well no.
And then you know,
he'd think about it and realize that,
you know,
he just passed up an opportunity for
chocolate ice cream.
And so that was a good trick to play on
a two year old as far as I was
concerned.
Yeah.
So,
but no is a really important word and
it's,
it's uh,
it's the place of the battleground
between the child.
It's a Friday and idea in some sense.
Although Freud identified this conflict
more with toilet training,
which is also a place where terrible
conflicts can emerge.
I knew a family who had a daughter who
would only use the toilet if she had a
diaper on.
Now that's,
that's defiant man.
You know,
she had full control over her system,
but there's no damn way she was going to
do what her mother wanted her to do.
She had to put a diaper on and then she
would go to the toilet.
So yes,
there was like a year's worth of warfare
around that.
I can tell you,
but you see the same thing at tables
with kids because people have a real
hard time,
and I don't know if it's always been
like this,
but modern people have a terrible time
trying to get their children to eat,
you know,
cause they're possessed by stupid ideas
like,
well,
the child will eat what's good for them.
It's like that's,
do you,
why would you expect a two year old to
do that?
You know,
who the hell eats what's good for them?
It's like Chocolatey.
Claire's had milkshakes for lunch.
You know,
that's the right thing to do and
children aren't stupid.
Or maybe they'll just eat hot dogs and
nothing else or maybe hot dogs and kraft
dinner.
That's all they ever wants.
Like you let your kid get away with
that.
Well what do you do then they're going
to grow up to be someone who isn't smart
enough to enjoy food that's not that
helpful.
It's like there's about six things in
life that are intrinsically pleasurable
and eating is one of them.
So you know,
you can warp them pretty nicely when
they're little about what they're going
to be allowed to eat and what not.
And you know,
you deny them a whole lifetime of
pleasure,
the pleasure that can be involved in
exploring new foods and eating new
cuisines and all of that.
But with,
especially with little monster children,
you know,
getting their,
getting their eating habits straight is
no joke.
You have to have rules.
There has to be consistency,
there has to be disciplined and there
has to be orderly timing.
You know,
cause the kid is also trying to organize
their,
their bodies are trying to organize
themselves with relationship to,
you know,
the rhythms of the day with sleeping and
waking and eating and all those things
that are the basic basic elements of,
of,
of a fundamentally healthy existence.
And trying to get a child to be in tune
with some sort of stable rhythm for some
children's is extremely difficult.
I've had clients who's sleeping and
eating was chronically disregulated.
So which basically meant that for their
whole life they never ate properly and
they never slept properly.
They never learned how to do it.
And it's partly because this little
battle here never occurred.
It's like there is a dragon at the
table.
That's partly why it's so important to
have your family around the table on a
fairly regular basis because you know,
that's a fundamental place where the
individual meets society,
human being,
share food.
It's like,
that's weird.
There aren't any other animals that do
that except fundamentally,
you know,
from mother to,
to pop.
But human beings share food and it's
really built into our systems at a deep
level.
You know,
I noticed with my daughter who was,
who was quite agreeable,
at least when she was young,
um,
I used to play tricks on her too.
So,
you know,
when she was at the table and she was
about 18 months old or so,
maybe you should have some dessert.
And then I'd ask her if I could have it
and she'd give it to me right away,
which of course made me feel horribly
guilty.
It's like stealing candy from a baby.
I felt like Mr.
Burns,
you know,
so,
but she'd handed to me right away and
with a smile on her face,
which I thought was absolutely
remarkable,
you know?
And,
and it was curious to see that that was
built in as an instinct at such an early
age.
By the time she was three,
you know,
this kid's age,
there's no damn way she's going to hand
me her dessert.
You know,
cause it was at that point,
I think somewhere around that point
that,
you know,
she had started to conceptualize
yourself more as an individual.
And that initial instinct that was a
sharing instinct had vanished,
you know,
then you have to kind of socialize it
back into place.
But anyways,
there's plenty of dragons at the table,
you know,
and you'll see that too.
Sometimes you go out to restaurants and
you know,
there'll be a family there with,
with their two year old or two and a
half year old.
And the thing is like completely out of
control.
You know,
it's like a cat with a clothes pin on
its tail running around the cafe or
restaurant doing nothing but causing
trouble.
And you know,
the thing about,
I had a client once who,
who was very immature man,
but he,
he had had a child and he wanted to sort
of,
you know,
wake up a bit and try to be a civilized
human being and not to screw up this kid
too terribly.
And he had this dream that um,
the crib for the baby was by the window
and that a bolt of lightening had struck
inside the window and let,
let a ball of lightening go in the House
and it was tearing all over the place.
You know,
and I thought when,
when I discussed the dream with him,
I thought,
well,
you know,
the dreams telling you about children's
let,
there's a powerful potential inside of
them.
But unless it's socialized properly and
integrated properly into culture,
then it can be a terrible destructive
force.
And,
and there's,
you know,
there's little doubt about that.
So,
well,
anyways,
it doesn't matter because billy's mother
has already decided that there's no such
thing as a dragon at the table.
And you know,
that means that when she takes her child
to a restaurant or to a dinner and it
misbehaves terribly,
that the child will continually
encounter nothing but fake smiles and
disapproval from all the adults that are
around it.
And that's going to be it's destiny for
the next number of years.
And so,
you know,
if you want to do something particularly
evil and vicious to your child,
then made sure that you fail to inform
them of any of the basic rules of
civilized behavior so that everywhere
they go,
the adults can pretend to tolerate them
and then really be pleased when they
leave and never invite them back.
Uh,
it's a great destiny.
So mother made some pancakes for billy,
but the drag and ate them all,
mother made some more.
But the dragon,
those two mother kept making pancakes
until she ran out of batter.
Billy only got one of them,
but he said that's all he really wanted.
Anyway.
So I'll tell you another story about
that.
So when I lived in Boston,
I had little kids and my wife took care
of some neighborhood little kids cause
she didn't have a green card and that
was,
she was home with the kids anyway.
So anyway,
she took care of some other little kids.
One of them would only eat hot dogs.
That was quite funny.
You'd only eat hotdogs that his mother's
place.
But at our house he had all of his lunch
and he was perfectly happy about it.
So I thought that was quite amusing too.
But anyways,
one day a neighbor came by and the
neighbor had a four year old child and
the neighbor was looking for someone to
take care of the child because her nanny
had been in a car accident and couldn't
take care of the child temporarily.
So the child had sort of been
circulating around neighborhood houses
for a couple of days and you know,
people were taking care of him.
Then he ended up at our house and um,
which was fine.
And so he's a cute little guy.
And,
uh,
his,
the mother came to the door and she said
she,
you know,
push the boy and he was kind of like
this.
It wasn't very happy.
And,
um,
she said he probably won't eat all day,
but that's okay.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's a,
that's a remarkably interesting
statement to,
you know,
to,
to put forth as a proposition.
The first time we meet your son,
it's like he won't eat all day,
which by the way,
is not okay.
It's not okay and you're going to tell
us that it's okay and you're going to
expect that.
We're just going to accept the fact that
you think it's okay.
And that's,
that's the whole story.
You deliver all that information in one
little sentence.
So I thought,
well that's pretty damn peculiar.
Uh,
I believe she was a psychologist too,
which was quite interesting.
So,
okay,
so that's fine.
So I went out to do something and there
was four kids playing in the house and
when I came back the little guy was in
the porch,
like wear the boots were at everything
and he was sort of standing there like
this and I thought,
hmm,
that's not good because there's all
these other kids,
like he should've been in there playing.
Hey that obviously that,
that's what a child is prime to do.
He should've been in there messing about
with,
I think there was a two year old and
three year old and another four year
old.
He should have beaten there,
you know,
causing trouble and having fun and
playing.
But he wasn't,
he was standing in the porch like this
and he wasn't happy.
He wasn't happy.
So I looked at him for a bit and then I
poked them a couple of times because I
thought,
you know,
if you're interacting with little kids,
they're very playful,
a,
they're kind of like puppies.
And so if you,
if you tease them a bit and tickled him
a bath,
then usually even if they're crabby,
you know,
a smile,
a breakout that despite their best
efforts and then they'll sort of giggle
and maybe,
you know,
they'll try to whack you away and they,
they,
they go into a play routine.
And although you may not know what
mammals like us have a place and also,
so we're intrinsically playful,
which is partly why we can get along
with dogs because of course dogs are
intrinsically playful and most people
know how to play with the dog.
And you know,
when a dog wants to play,
right,
because it sort of puts his paws down
and looks up at you and sort of grands
and puts its tail in the air and goes
like Das.
It's like clue in primate,
you know,
it's time to engage in some playing and
you basically know how to do that.
And even the dog knows how to do that.
So I'm poking this kid and trying to get
him to smile,
but there's no damn way,
you know,
I'm poking him.
He's just ignoring me like mad.
And I thought that's not good.
You know,
because you don't want your four year
old to have learned that you should.
You should.
That it's okay to ignore adults or that
you should ignore adults or that you can
ignore adults.
That's all bad because the world's full
of adults and they know a lot of things
and they control all the resources and
so you better get along with them.
Plus you're going to end up as an adult
for most of your life.
So if the general,
you know,
if the first rule is adults can and
should be ignored,
then what the hell are you headed for?
You know,
and it's one of the reasons that it's
really useful to make sure the children
respect adults because they're going to
be adults.
So if they don't respect adults,
then of course they don't have any
respect for what they're going to be.
Why the hell grow up?
You end up like Peter Pan Because that's
what Peter Parents about,
right?
Peter Pan Wants to stay at Neverland
with the lost boys where,
where there's no responsibility because
you know,
he looks at the future and only sees his
captain hook a tyrant who's afraid of
death.
That's the crocodile,
right?
That's chasing him with a clock in its
stomach.
And it's the same thing as this dragon.
So you know,
kids have to respect adults.
It's you doing them a disservice if they
don't.
So,
okay,
so fine,
I'm poking this kid.
There's just no damn way.
I'm not getting anywhere with them.
And I thought this isn't good.
There's something deeply wrong with this
little kid.
So that's fine.
So then we sit all the kids down for
lunch and the rule is you're damn lunch
and be thankful for it because you think
about this,
there's,
Leonard Cohen wrote this song once
about,
I don't remember the song particularly,
but he talked about the homicidal
bitching that goes down in every kitchen
about who is going to serve and who's
going to eat.
It's like if you haven't encountered
that,
then there's something terribly wrong.
You know,
so because a lot of the tension in
households is domestic tension,
the tension between husbands and wives
or husbands,
wives and children.
It's like just who the hell is going to
do the domestic duties and how and when,
and the answer can't be,
well,
we're not going to do them because then
you know,
you eat cheetos and popcorn and you know
for the rest of your life and that's not
good.
It's got to the point in England because
the domestic situations have
deteriorated.
The rituals of deteriorated to such a
point that about one third at families
no longer have a dining room table and
you can buy precooked hard boiled eggs.
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
You know,
it's,
it's not a good thing and you might
yourself,
why the hell everyone is either fat or
has an eating disorder.
And you know,
part of the reason is is that the entire
domestic routine around regulating food
intake has disappeared.
That's a terrible thing for people
because we're social eaters.
So you might say,
well,
if you sit down with a bunch of other
people at a table,
how much should you eat?
And the answer is you should eat on
average what everyone else eats.
And that's exactly what you do.
Even if you don't notice it,
you know,
people are so wired into,
we did experiments like this.
If you,
if you bring on,
or if you bring undergraduates who don't
know each other into a lab and you give
them a snack while they're doing
something like watching a movie,
they will eat the same number of chips.
So you know,
if one of the meets the whole half the
thing,
the other real you'd have if one only
has one,
the other only have one.
The correlation between the food intake
between the dyads was about 0.8
it was staggering.
It seemed to be a little higher for
extroverts than for introverts,
but it was remarkably,
remarkably can coordinate.
You can understand why,
right?
Because human beings share food.
It's like you are not going to be a
popular tribes person if you eat,
you know,
30% of the food when food is in short
supply,
you better be bloody awake and make sure
that you don't take more than your
share.
And you know,
it's a fundamental element of human
nature to do that.
And you know,
and we also regulate our sense of
satiety by cues that are external to us.
So regulating our food intake also
because we're omnivores turns out to be
a tremendously difficult thing.
And well,
anyways,
back to this kid.
So we bring all the kids to the table
and they're sitting around in there
having lunch.
And the rule is,
as I said,
eat what is in front of you and be
pleased and happy about it.
So you might say,
well why would that also be a rule?
It's like,
okay,
put yourself in this position now
because you'll be in this position.
You're going to cook your damn kids some
lunch and you're going to do that.
Well let's,
let's calculate it out.
Cause I liked doing arithmetic.
So let's say it takes you half an hour a
day and you do it seven days a week.
But we'll multiply that by three cause
there's three meals.
So it's an hour and a half a day,
right?
So,
okay fine.
Seven times an hour and a half has
roughly 10 so it's 10 hours a week.
It's 40 hours a month,
right?
40 hours a month is a full work week.
So 40 hours a month times 1212 full work
weeks,
right?
Yes.
That's three full months of 40 hour days
of cooking something for your damn kid.
Now that's a lot of time.
And then you're going to do that for 18
years.
So then you might ask yourself,
what sort of response do you need from
your child in order to not feel
resentful and miserable about the fact
that you have to do that for three
bloody months this year.
And you just have to think about this.
And this is also why it's necessary to
know that inside yourself you carry a
monster.
Just like the world outside you carries
a monster.
Do not think that you're going to be
able to maintain a healthy attitude
towards your child or towards food or
towards yourself.
If all you can muster up for the effort
of cooking and preparing food is the
attitude of a slave and continual
punishment from the people that you're
offering food too.
It's like,
who the hell wants that?
So you want to teach the miserable
little lighter that he's lucky that
there's any food there at all.
And that the proper attitude is to say,
really thank you very much mom or thank
you very much dad.
I'm glad that you produce something and
then you know,
you can be all happy about the fact that
you were,
you know,
slaving away in the kitchen and you can
like your kid.
So,
and you know,
you might think,
well everybody likes their kids.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
No that's not true.
That's not true.
And now,
and then,
you know,
you read in the newspaper about someone
who's,
you know,
being pushed a little bit too far on
some day that they're unemployed and
hung over and you know,
the relationship has just broken up and
they do something absolutely brutal to
their child.
And you think,
well,
how could anyone do that?
It's like there's a lot of history of
terrible interactions between the mother
and the child or the father and the
child before something like that
happens.
So,
you know,
if you want to protect your child
against the beast that's inside you,
you might want to teach them to treat
you with some respect so that you're
much more likely to be a civilized human
being around them.
So,
all right,
so anyway,
so this kid sitting there and there's no
damn way he's going to eat anything.
Okay?
So we decided we're going to feed him,
which I'm an expert at because my,
my son,
the one who said no all the time,
he was the most stubborn little cus you
could possibly imagine.
And one time when he was about nine
months old,
he got ahold of the spoon and it was
like he was not going to be fed anymore.
Hey.
So that's fine.
Good.
You know,
it's like feed yourself but no kids a,
they're too damn curious and playful
really to feed themselves.
So you sit them in a high chair and then
you know,
they fleeing the food onto the floor
cause that's pretty cool.
And they could watch that over and over,
you know,
or they mess around with it or maybe
they,
you know,
put some in Mum's hair cause that's
interesting to it.
They have two or three bites and then
they're not ravenous and then they're
much more interested in playing.
And that's fine except that if the kid
does need then it gets crabby and you
know,
whiny and miserable and then it just
disturbs the mother or the father and
then it won't sleep at night.
It's like that's no good.
So after about three days of that,
I took the spoon back from him and he
was not happy about that man trying to
get that little kid to eat.
Once I got the spoon,
it was like a four hour battle.
It was really remarkable.
So I,
I,
I had a lot of respect for his ability
just to withstand stubbornness,
you know?
But I'd learned by that time as a parent
that like if you want to discipline your
child,
you,
there's an attitude you have to take,
which is I am going to win this.
Like I don't care how stubborn you are,
I am going to win.
And because I know I'm going to win,
I'm not going to get angry.
I'm just going to out stubborn you.
And so,
so I take up some food and put it in
front of him.
He go like this.
So that was a good trick.
And so I tried get the food in there and
his teeth regretted.
So I poke him,
you know,
poke,
poke.
And after about 10 pokes,
he'd get annoyed and go and I put the
food yet.
And then he tried to spit it out so I'd
hold it.
He had in this.
So then,
so that was like three minutes,
you know,
and then we did it with another
spoonful.
And you know,
after about,
I'd say an hour of this,
my wife had to leave because it was like
she just couldn't handle it.
And about an hour after this,
he decided that,
you know,
it was okayed and that he would let me
feed them.
But like it was brutal and it was
amazing.
I mean,
little kids are so damn tough,
you know,
they're really cute and everything and,
but they're so tough,
you just can't believe it.
So anyways,
so we had this good at the table and he
was not going to eat.
So my wife who'd learned these tricks by
this time decided to feed him and he had
a lot of,
sort of nine month old or eight month
old behaviors because you know,
kids have different strategies of
resistance if they don't want to do
something.
And those strategies get more
sophisticated as they get older.
But,
and he had some strategies,
but they weren't sophisticated,
you know,
like he didn't make jokes or knock this
spoon way or,
or get angry or,
or run away or any of those things.
He did kind of nine month old things,
which means he just put his head down
and when she put the spoon towards him,
he just avert his head one way or
another.
So.
So that was interesting because I knew
that his parents had given up feeding
him when he was about eight or nine
months old because those tricks worked.
And so that's why she could come to the
house and saying,
he probably won't eat all day.
But that's all right.
Which it isn't.
It's not.
All right.
So find,
so my wife is trying to feed him and he
doesn't open his mouth,
so she pokes from Tibet and sooner or
later he gets mad and you know,
goes ah,
and she puts the food in and she does.
And then she pats him on the head as
soon as he swallows it and says,
look,
you're being a really good kid.
You know,
you're doing a good job.
And then,
so he's wondering what the Hell is going
on?
And then it was so interesting because
she kept feeding him and he was still
doing this,
but as she patted him on the head,
he'd be doing this and he'd open his
mouth.
So it was like there was this weird
conflict between his habitual behavior
and this thing that was being
reinforced.
So then she'd,
you know,
put food in and pat him and he,
he'd be kind of happy about that.
And then he'd go back to his routine.
And then she did that for,
I think about 20 minutes.
It wasn't disruptive like all the other
kids ate.
They didn't even really notice what was
going on.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a big deal,
you know,
but I was watching because I knew
something was up because the stupid
thing that his mother said,
and then the fact that he wouldn't play,
and he ignored me.
I thought,
Nah,
there's some reading,
not good here.
There's dragon here.
And it's a big one.
So she feeds him and then he finishes
the whole bull.
It's like,
and she says,
you're a good boy.
You ate the whole bull and Jesus,
you should have seen what happened to
that kid.
Man,
it just about broke my heart.
Like really?
Like his eyes got big and he smiled and
he was just like,
he was super thrilled because he'd
finally accomplished this absolute basic
necessity that he hadn't mastered in
four years.
He finally got it right and you think of
of meals that he went through either
being ignored or failing three times a
day for like three years.
Nothing but failure and bad responses
and you know,
he didn't turn,
realized all that he thought he was a
bad kid and then all of a sudden post he
figured this out and you know,
get a little reward for it.
It was like he just lit up and that
whole shell that he had on that he was
like using to protect himself when he
was in the porch.
That just melted away.
It was like,
it was horrifying and amazing at the
same time.
And then he followed my wife around
after that in the house,
just like a puppy dog.
Like he wouldn't get,
he would not get more than one foot away
from her.
It was unbelievable.
And then we went downstairs to watch
like a movie with the kids and she sat
on a rocking chair and he climbed right
up on her lap and grabbed her just like
that.
Harlow monkey grabbed the,
you know,
the little soft mother instead of the
wire.
He mother pm's like this and he was like
that for like two hours.
He wouldn't let her go.
So then the mother came home,
his mother came home and she came
downstairs and she looked at what was
going on,
you know,
and this kid was like glommed onto my
wife and she looked at her and she said,
oh,
supermom.
And you know,
took her kid and went home.
It's like Jesus,
like if you don't think there's a dragon
and that story,
man,
you are not listening to it.
It was not good.
And her response at the end was
terrible.
She should have said,
well,
how'd you get them to eat?
It's like,
what?
What the hell is he doing?
Like hugging you?
He never does that to me.
No Way,
man.
She was going to let that piece of
information in and it's no wonder
because the dragon and that story was
her and it was something she did not
want to admit and she was willing,
perfectly willing to sacrifice her child
to that,
to her failure to realize that she could
be a dragon.
So that meant that the child was the
problem and that's a hell of a thing to
do to a four year old.
So it was not pleasant.
It was really not pleasant.
In fact,
we probably did damage to the child by
actually getting them to do something
good.
A because we opened up him up to the
possibility that he could behave
properly and be rewarded for that.
And that gave them hope.
And so you can bloody well be sure that
that hope was dispensed with the next
day
salt.
And that's why billy doesn't get
anything to eat.
Yes.
Oh No,
I'd still do it because you know the
child,
at least the child got to learn that
there was adult somewhere in the world
that would pay attention to them.
You know,
so I mean,
yes.
Well,
you have to,
you know,
you can't let things that aren't right
or occur under your,
under your supervision,
you know,
it's not appropriate.
And you should pay attention to little
kids.
You know,
they're,
they're remarkable little things and you
know,
they there,
if you pay attention to your kids,
you'll never have better companions.
You know,
children,
they're remarkable.
They're really easy to get along with.
Unless they're hungry or tired or hot or
cold.
It's like you should be able to deal
with that.
Writes for things.
It's like,
is he hot?
Is He called his,
he hungry?
You know,
does he have to go to the bathroom?
That's it.
And then,
you know,
wherever you take them,
they're happy until they get tired or
hot or cold or hungry.
And by that time,
you're probably one of those things.
But you're too stupid to notice.
So the kid will notice first and then
you're done.
But it's fun.
And the kids are like,
they're like little,
they don't have any latent inhibition,
technically,
I think is what's going on.
But when you're around little kids,
you know you're no longer cynical
because they still see the world and you
can't because you're old and stupid and
blind and you know the kid can still see
the world.
And so when you take the kids around,
you can see the world again because you
can see it through their eyes and that's
such a gift.
It's just unbelievable.
So you know,
you don't want to mess with that and you
don't want to be the one that's
responsible for deciding that the kid
happens to be the monster that you won't
admit you are.
And believe me,
you're a monster.
There's absolutely no doubt about it.
The question is only do you know it and
are you going to do something about it?
And if you think that's wrong,
then well,
you know,
good luck to you.
Belly went upstairs to brush his teeth.
Mothers started clearing the table.
The dragon who is quite as big as
mothered by this time,
that's not so good,
right?
Made himself comfortable on the hall rug
and went to sleep.
So now she's ignored something for so
long that it's basically her size.
You know,
I've seen people in therapy talking
about their marriages when they're sort
of on the verge of divorce,
you know,
and uh,
they have dragons that they,
that the person brings with them that
are their size or bigger.
And what that means in some sense is
that they've ignored certain things for
so long that the problem has become so
complex and multifaceted and
multi-headed that they no longer have
the energy or the ability to solve it.
So it's like,
you know,
I tried to calculate at certain times
how many decisions that you make during
the day,
you know,
whether you're going to react one way or
another and maybe you're doing that in
the context of a relationship.
You know,
and you know,
most of you know,
if you've had a relationship of any
length,
you know,
more than a couple of months,
you start to actually interact with the
person rather than your idea of the
person.
And you know,
there are conflicts and part of them are
because you're both stupid,
neurotic and ignorant and half crazy.
And some of them are because life has
real problems and there's really
difficult things like conflicts of
interest that have to be worked out.
It's really hard and you know you can,
with each interaction that you have
within a relationship,
you basically decide whether you're
going to address the reality that's in
front of you or whether you're going to
let it slide.
And you know,
if you let 10 or 20 things slide a day,
those are all things that would in
principle have to be addressed in order
to keep the relationship pristine and,
and functional and adapted to the
current situation.
You let 20 things like that slide a day.
It's like 150 a week or 600 a month or
7,000
a year and you do that for 10 years,
then it's 75,000
things that you haven't dealt with.
And so then you go to therapy and was
saying,
our marriage isn't so good.
And you know,
you look behind it,
you see,
oh there's 75,000
problems that you haven't solved.
It's like good luck starting now.
You know,
you just can't do it.
And at that point,
maybe there's no way out divorced.
It's like good luck with that.
Especially if you have children.
It's like you might as well have
terminal cancer.
You know,
getting divorced with children is no
joke.
And I've seen people's lives absolutely
demolished by that so that there was no
hope they could recover.
It's really not good.
I mean sometimes it works and the people
are,
you know,
they can communicate enough to be
reasonable about the,
about the distribution of assets and,
and the children's custody.
But you know,
if they're not reasonable,
whoa,
my God,
it's just awful.
So don't generate problems around
yourself by avoiding unnecessary things
until the problem is so big that it's
bigger than you because you're basically
done at that point.
You can't fix it.
You don't have the energy.
So you can tell when a couples like
that,
because they keep bringing up things
from the past like 20 year ago,
things,
you know,
he's always like,
you're,
you've,
you've always been like that.
You're like that now.
And you'll always be like that in the
future.
It's like that's no way to begin to
negotiation.
And then you can remember something that
happened 20 years ago and bring it up.
It's like,
that'll make you happy.
By the time billy came back downstairs,
the dragon had grown so much.
He filled the hall.
Billy only had to go around by way of
the living room to get to where his
mother was.
I didn't know dragons grew so fast at
billy.
There's no such thing as a dragon.
Said mother firmly.
Yeah,
cleaning the downstairs took mother all
morning.
What was the dragon in the way?
And having to climb in and out of
windows to get from room to room.
It's like that's a really funny one day
because it's like,
it's so obvious now that there's
something up,
but she's still not going to admit it.
And so,
you know,
I've,
I've been in places like that to where
there's so much interpersonal tension
among the participants and so many
pathological things going on in the
household that nothing simple can get
done.
You know?
So like maybe that the job of making a
tuna sandwich takes like two hours
because there's nothing,
but first of all,
nobody can find anything to make it
with.
And you know,
the fridge is empty and maybe the tuna
cans or six years old and the breads all
moldy and stale.
And then even if that wasn't the case,
they can't figure out who the hell is
going to go shopping.
And then even if they could manage that,
there'd be big fight around,
you know,
what should be on the sandwich and how
much tuna.
And so the,
the point of this little part of the
story is that,
you know,
a simple task is only a simple task.
If there aren't all sorts of impediments
around cluttering it up,
you know,
and,
and if,
and if there are impediments like that
cluttering it up,
then you just can't get it done.
And then you can see why that's so
terribly stressful.
Because what it means in part is that
there is no way that you can just do
something straight forward with ease.
Everything is about everything all the
time.
It's like,
oh,
it's awful.
It's awful.
And it's very,
very common.
You know,
you see couples all the time.
This is a modern problem.
You know,
one of the advantages to traditional
divisions of labor is that everybody
knows what to do.
Now you might say,
well that's not fair.
It's like,
yeah,
okay fine.
It's not fair.
That's probably true.
The question is what the hell is the
alternative?
And the alternative is you have to
negotiate every single task.
So you know,
if you're going to habit with someone at
some point in the future,
here's your options.
Slavery,
tyranny or negotiation.
So you can be the slave,
you can be the tyrant or you can
negotiate.
But the problem is in the absence of
routine and ritual and tradition,
there's no rules.
So everything has to be negotiated.
And the problem with that is most people
can't negotiate.
They don't know how,
you know,
cause the negotiation,
it's a complex process and people are
very unlikely to engage in it.
So when I'm,
when I'm trying to get people to make
decisions,
when they,
when they have to deal with something
that's very complicated,
the first thing I do is I say,
okay,
look,
let,
let's lay out the problem space.
Okay,
all we're going to do is discuss what
might be going on here.
We're not going to jump to any
conclusions about whether any of these
theories are correct.
We're just going to contemplate them.
And right away there's resistance to
that because it's very difficult for
people to separate a hypothesis about
the way things are from a description of
the way things are.
So they get afraid that as soon as you
discuss something in a certain way that
that's the way it's going to be.
And so they can't even lay out the
problem space.
So that's the first impediment to
negotiation.
And then another impediment is,
um,
they can define what they want,
you know,
so like if you and I are going to
negotiate about something,
one of the things you need to know is
what I could do that would satisfy you.
And if the answer is,
well,
if you knew me better,
you'd know what would satisfy me.
Which is a very common answer.
It's like I'm,
I'm hatched right from the beginning
because like I'm stupid.
I don't know what will satisfy you.
I don't even know what will satisfy me.
You have to,
you have to tell me,
cause I'm not very bright.
It's like,
what do you want?
Well I don't know.
It's like,
oh no,
that's not good.
It's like,
no,
we have two problems.
The problem and whatever would make you
happy.
It's like,
it's terrible.
And then you have to lay out the
solution space.
It's like,
what?
We could do it this way or we could do
it this way or we could do it this way,
or here's another option,
or this is an option.
And like why don't you think those
through?
It's like,
oh,
that's a whole set of multiple
realities.
It's overwhelming.
It's like,
I'm not doing that.
I'm tired of this discussion.
I'm gone.
So,
so there's a dragon in everyone's house
of that size now because no one knows
what to do and no one knows how to solve
the problem of what to do because people
don't know how to negotiate.
They just aren't good at it.
It's hard to negotiate,
you know,
cause you have to suspend your judgment
and you have to have a symbolic war that
doesn't erupt into a real war.
And then you have to solve it and then
people have to agree to the solution and
then they have to enact a solution,
right?
They have to be,
they have to be,
they have to what?
Act Out their word once the solution has
been negotiated and it happens,
but it's very difficult.
So people avoid it all the time and then
everything becomes incredibly
complicated.
I went to her house once quite regularly
where the husband refused to,
he was kind of a traditionalist,
you know,
and he refused to ever thank his wife
for doing anything that was domestically
related,
like cooking now.
And she also had a career and it was,
you know,
a pretty demanding careers.
So it wasn't self evident that she
should be the one that was doing this,
but that doesn't matter.
You know,
she could cook but she wouldn't.
And so every time I went there,
I had the most God awful food.
It was just staggeringly terrible.
You know,
everything had done,
been done to that food to torture it,
that add intelligent and irritated
person could possibly do.
And so the price that was being paid in
that and the kids would neat and it's No
God damn wonder.
You know?
It's like who would eat that?
And so the price the family was paying
for not negotiating around this complex
operation because running a domestic,
okay.
Economy is very complex operation.
The price they paid for it was,
every single meal was like curdled with
resentment and the food quality was
terrible and everyone was angry.
It's like,
oh my God,
that's like four hours a day of that.
You know,
that's like a quarter of your waking
life.
So,
and you know,
after engaging in that sort of
interaction with your husband or your
wife for like a quarter of the day for
10 years,
you can be sure that whatever goodwill
you might have stored up is pretty much
evaporated.
So,
you know,
one thing that you might think about,
and this is counter intuitive,
you know,
because people think what are the most
important events in your life?
And you know,
no one is going to say breakfast.
You know,
you think,
well I went to Europe for two weeks this
summer,
something like that.
It's like all that stuff's irrelevant.
Who Cares about that?
Exceptions are irrelevant.
Your life is made up of the things you
do every day.
That's what it's made up of.
So,
you know,
I know how many thousands of hours
you're going to spend having breakfast
over the,
you know,
the course of your life.
But it's going to be something like one
16th of the time you have left.
So let's say you've got eight years
left,
that means you're gonna have,
you're gonna have spent five years
having breakfast.
It's like get it right.
You know,
cause about I would say about half of
your life is routine and if you get the
routines right,
you know,
so everybody sits down and meals real
good and everybody's happy about it and
all the little decisions have been
distributed property.
It's like Poof,
half your life is good.
So you know and you won't get sat and
have an eating disorder,
which is also,
it's also kind of a plus or you won't
get as fat or have as much of an eating
disorder by noon.
The dragon filled doubts,
it's head hung out the front door.
It's tail hung out the back door and
there wasn't a room in the house that
didn't have some part of the dragon in
it.
Hmm.
I bet that there is a house like that on
some of you will live.
You know where there's a lot of houses,
somebody live in apartments,
it doesn't really matter.
But I bet you if you live in a house on
a block of houses,
there's at least one house on that
street where the tail of the dragon has
started to come out of the house.
And you know what,
that's like gay because it's the house
that you don't really want to look at
when you walk by.
You know,
and maybe,
I don't know,
that needs a new roof and like the doors
a little bit crooked and the law and
isn't cotton.
You know,
there's some rusty things lying around
there and like it's just not taken care
of.
And you know,
and maybe you know from the gossip in
the neighborhood too,
that there's something going on in that
house that is just not good and it's got
to the point where it's so not good that
it's starting to spread itself out
beyond the domestic confines of the
house.
So you know,
you love,
you run into people like that now.
And then too,
you'll notice this.
So you know,
sometimes,
I don't know if this has happened to him
of you,
but it might have tapped you in some
ways.
You know that there,
there was people who can't not tell you
everything about what's going on in
their life,
even if you've hardly even met them.
If you see someone who's really in
trouble,
you know you'll sit on the bus and
somebody who's clearly on the road to
being thoroughly de deranged,
we'll sit down beside you and they'll
start telling you about the problems of
their life.
It's like,
you know that the dragon that they're
dealing with is so big that they can't
even contain it.
There are so desperate to have it dealt
with that they can't not talk about it.
You know?
And there's lots of people like that.
They're the ones,
what is that stupid little phrase?
Tmi.
Is that right?
Too much information.
It's like,
yeah,
well why does that happen?
It's because people are dealing with
anomalies and unexpected occurrences and
tragedies and they cannot articulate a
solution.
And most people think by talking,
which is also part of the reason that
therapy works.
It's right.
Well do you think I doubted you might,
but very few people think,
you know?
And so if you want to solve a problem,
you want to talk it over with a friend.
And so you know,
you might just think that you're talking
about the problem sort of.
You know what the problem is,
but you're talking about.
So you don't,
when you talk about it,
you articulate the problem space.
You start to generate potential
hypotheses about solutions.
But more than that,
if you're talking to someone,
you can watch them just like the little
kid with the mouse would watch the
mother.
It's like,
well,
here's what I think the problem is.
And if you go,
you know you're listening and you go
like that,
you roll your eyes,
you know,
it's a hint to the person that maybe
that's not the most appropriate way to
formulate the problem.
Now maybe you don't roll your eyes,
but you know you don't encourage them.
Or maybe they tell you what the problem
is and you're really actively engaged
in.
You're nodding.
Well then they know that maybe they
formulated the way someone have sane and
tolerable would formulate it and then
they can walk through the solution.
So,
so when you sit down beside someone and
they have to tell you everything,
one of the things that you know is that
they don't have anyone to listen to
them.
And part of what happens in therapy and
a huge part of it is that you just
listened.
I have one client that's,
that's all I ever do with her.
She comes in twice,
once every two weeks and I just sit
there and listen to her for an hour and
now I can maybe have a bit of a
discussion with her for the last 10
minutes.
But if I try to say anything for the
first 50 minutes,
she just looks kinda irritated.
And you know,
it's like I've interrupted the flow of
the,
of the interaction and she's alone.
She's an everybody to talk to.
So,
you know,
she wants to listen to herself think and
she can't do that by herself.
She has to have someone to do it with.
And so,
you know,
people think by talking and some people
have no one to talk to and so their
problems start to spill out.
And you know,
by that time you can't even help them
usually because if you listen for three
years,
it wouldn't be enough listening.
He just listen forever and you'd never
get to the bottom of it.
And the dragon awoke from his nap.
He was hungry.
Bakery truck went by,
the smell of fresh bread was more than
the dragon could resist.
The dragon ran down the street after the
bakery truck,
the house went along of course like the
shell on a snail.
Cool.
Read this book a while back,
I think it was called the glass castle.
It's very,
very cool book.
It's about this woman whose parents were
extremely creative and intelligent and
unbelievably unconscientious like just
so unconscientious that it was mind
boggling,
disorderly and non industrious.
And,
and so they were,
they were a little bit on the
psychopathic edge of things and you
know,
her father would up all sorts of new
ideas and many of them were actually
brilliant because he was no idiot,
but he was kind of a petty crook and you
know,
he'd get gambling trouble and,
and you know,
cheap people at cards and not pay his
bills and so on.
And so like every three months they had
to move.
And like if you have to move every three
months,
you know that the dragon in your
household has got so big that it's
actually the one that's carrying around
the house and that happens to people a
lot.
And so their lives are so disorganized
they can't even stay in one place for
any length of time.
No.
So
the mailman was just coming up the paths
with some mail for the big speeds when
their house rush past him and headed
down the street,
he chased it for a few blogs but he
couldn't catch it.
Okay.
Oh,
if you move enough and you're unstable
enough,
then none of the rest of society can
communicate with you or stay in touch
with you and that deprives you of all
the benefits that a certain degree of
predictability would confer upon you.
Like you don't get your mail.
Mr.
Buck bixby.
He's quite a genius too.
When mixture,
Mr Bixby came home for lunch,
the first thing he noticed was that this
house was gone.
It's like sometimes people don't notice
things until it's got to that point.
Right.
Because now and then you hear a story
about someone coming home and like their
wife has packed up and taken the
children and that was the end of that
and the person says,
well,
I never saw that coming.
It's like right,
you never saw it coming.
And Mr Bixby,
conventional sort of guy,
a little bit on the clueless side.
Obvious.
Obviously he didn't know what the hell
was going on.
He comes home and his house is gone and
it's a neighbor that has to tell him
where it went.
It's like he's just as inattentive as
his wife.
Okay.
Mr Bixby got in his car and went looking
for the house where he studied all the
houses as he drove along.
Finally he saw one that looked familiar
belly and Mrs Bixby,
we're waving from an upstairs window.
Okay.
Mr Bixby climbed over the dragon's head
onto the porch roof and through the
upstairs window.
How did this happen,
Mr?
Bixby asked.
That's a good question.
Right,
and that's where the story actually
starts to turn around because somebody
finally admits that there's a problem.
So they say,
well,
what's going on?
Which is to say there is a problem,
you know,
because when you make a statement,
the statement has all sorts of
inferential meanings that are attached
to it.
And just to say,
well what's the problem is also to say,
well that there is a problem and to say
that it's worthwhile formulating the
statement that a problem and that it's
worthwhile thinking about it,
that's a big move.
You know,
one of the things that Carl Rogers said
about therapy and he's absolutely right
about this,
is that there are preconditions for
therapeutic improvement and one of them
is the person who comes for therapy has
to admit that there's a problem before
they come and they have to want to have
a solution.
And if that situation isn't there,
you can't do anything with them.
I,
I had people assigned to me at sometimes
by the court,
it's like court assigned therapy.
That is not useful because it's like the
person has to say,
while I'm in trouble and there could be
a solution,
you know,
otherwise they're just sitting there
like this,
you know,
sort of looking at you.
Or I had one guy who was a real
psychopath.
He was a child abuser and you know,
all he did the whole bloody therapeutic
that the whole time I was with was brag
about what a pillar of community he was.
You know,
and I,
he was really quite psychopathic,
so I tried to at least convince him
that,
you know,
he was likely to continue to get in
trouble if he didn't stop what he was
doing.
But you know,
he was also one of those people who knew
absolutely everything and there was
nothing at all that anybody could ever
tell him.
And you know,
it was,
it was just like there was,
I was,
it wasn't any more useful than it would
have been if I wasn't even in the room
is completely pointless.
So because he didn't have a problem,
everybody else had a problem.
Dragon wagged his tail happily then even
faster than it had grown.
The dragon started getting smaller.
Sooner is Kipnis sized again.
I don't mind dragons this size said
mother,
she's certainly come around.
Why did it have to grow so big?
I'm not sure said belly,
but I think it just wanted to be
noticed.
It's a tremendously profound little
story,
you know,
because it's got echoes of the,
of the,
of Paradise and paradise lost in it.
The dragon and the dragon in the garden.
But it's even better than that because
it shows how dangerous it is to ignore
things.
And then it caps it off with the
proposition that even if it's a bloody
dragon,
if you just admitted to there,
oh,
and look at it,
there's a high probability that will
shrink to a manageable size.
You could hardly ask for a better
ending.
Right.
Because you know,
you maybe they,
something magic happens in the
thunderbolt,
gets rid of the dragon,
you know,
it's,
it's the wrong kind of ending.
This is,
yeah,
you're stuck with a dragon.
But you know,
maybe if you pay attention to the God
damn thing,
then not only does it stay kitten sized,
which isn't so bad,
but you can deal with it.
And then there's something else.
It's like,
do you really want a household with no
dragons?
You know,
like imagine that because people,
one of the things Dostoyevsky pointed
out in,
in his,
this was in notes from underground,
which is a very powerful commentary on
the foolishness of utopianism.
You know,
so if you,
if you produced a utopia,
there wouldn't be any snakes in it,
right?
Cause Utopia is where everything's
perfect.
It's like,
what the hell would you do in a utopia?
You know,
you just sit there while everything was
perfect.
What we're seriously,
do you really want everything to be
perfect or do you want to be surrounded
by manageable problems that you can make
a meaningful contribution to?
Well that seems better.
You know,
so,
so there's something better than
perfection.
It's weird.
And what's better than perfection is
manageable imperfection because it gives
you something to do.
And so one of the things Dostoevsky
said,
this was back in the late 18 hundreds he
utopia's will never work because people
are basically somewhat insane.
And if things were too perfect around
them,
all the go do is go around and smash
things until something interesting
happens so that they had something to
do.
And that that seems to be,
you know,
precisely right.
So the moral of the story here is don't
ignore the Damn Dragon,
but there's more than that too.
It's like if you attend to it properly,
if you have your eyes open,
then maybe the thing will stay
manageable.
And that's a lovely ending.
I mean,
one of the things we know,
for example,
if you're dealing with people who have
an anxiety disorder,
maybe they had an agoraphobic,
you know,
they're very terrified.
Often they're terrified of death,
but they're really terrified of is this,
they're terrified that they'll have a
painful and sudden sort of death in
public while people are watching
themselves make a fool of themselves
while they're dying.
So there's two elements to it.
There's the,
the,
the fear of mortal vulnerability,
which is real.
You know,
and sometimes people develop agoraphobic
after they've had heart palpitations or
something like that,
you know?
And so there's dragon inside when think,
well my God,
you know,
I might die.
And so then they go to the emergency
ward three or four times when they have
panic attacks because they're thinking
they have heart attacks.
And what are they afraid of?
Well,
they've just figured out that,
you know,
they might be walking down the street
one day and die and it's like,
yes,
that could happen.
You know?
And it's often people who are quite
dependent,
who've been dependent for much of their
life and whose dependency relationships
have been disrupted in some way that
start to manifest the symptoms.
But then if you dig a little bit deeper,
there are also concerned about the fact
that you know,
well it's something unbearable is
happening to them physiologically.
They'll expose themselves to the public
and so there'll be watched.
So it's kind of,
it's both social judgment plus mortality
fear,
which is like the sum of all fears in
some sense.
If you treat agoraphobic people,
what's quite interesting is you actually
don't ever convince them that the world
is more,
is less dangerous than they have now
realized.
And the reason for that is it isn't less
dangerous than they've now realized.
They had just never realized that.
Right.
And so they'd never really grown up.
And so then you expose them to
situations of danger and you might say,
well,
they habituate and become less
frightened.
It's like that isn't really what the
evidence suggests.
What the evidence suggests is that they
become braver,
which is way better because the world is
dangerous.
And so,
you know,
if I had to fix you to cure you of your
anxiety disorder,
I have to say,
look,
everything's going to be all right.
It's like,
no,
you've already figured out that
everything is not going to be all right.
And so then that question is,
well,
once you figured out that everything is
not going to be all right,
what are you going to do?
And the answer to that is there might be
a lot more to you than you think.
And it could easily be that regardless
of,
you know,
how fragile you think you are and how
little of you there is,
that might just be wrong.
You know?
And if you exposed yourself to things
that were challenging and frightening,
you'd find out that the monster that you
have inside of you has real utility
because you're a lot more dangerous.
And capable than you think.
And that is what people who are treated
for anxiety disorders conclude.
They think,
oh,
you know,
so maybe you,
it's usually women that have,
they have agoraphobic.
It's quite interesting.
So maybe you get the woman so she can
now go on subways again and she can take
the Boston,
she can go in elevators and then she
goes home and have this big fight with
her husband,
which he hasn't done in 20 years because
she's being too timid,
you know?
And so what she's learned is,
Hey,
I'm not as useless as I think.
I don't need as much protection as I
thought I needed.
I can stand up for myself and you know,
then she can take on other challenges
that she wouldn't have been able to take
on before because you've taught her that
she's brave.
That is possible to be brave and
courageous and that if you do that,
it actually works.
And that's really what happens at the
end of the story.
It's like,
you know,
Mr Bixby finally thinks while there is,
the problem here,
we should figure out what it is.
And the kid says what it is and everyone
listens and all of a sudden poof.
You know,
it's back to manageable proportions.
And so one,
one of there aren't that many optimistic
things in philosophy or in psychology or
in life that are truly optimistic and
reliable.
But one of the things that is both
optimistic and reliable is you might be
a hell of a lot tougher than you think.
And so you know,
when you're,
when you're assaulted as you will be
throughout your life by terrible things
happening,
you know,
for example,
at some point when some of you've
already done this,
you're going to have to deal say with
the death of a parent,
you know,
you can do that,
and in a way that's terrible.
It's terrible that you can do that
because you might think,
well,
if he really loved your parent,
you know,
and they die,
then the logical and appropriate thing
is to fall apart and never be put back
together because anything less would
mean that you didn't have sufficient
love.
It's like,
no,
well,
you know,
you are a bit of a monster.
And it turns out that you can lose a lot
more than you think and you can still
move forward.
And,
and even more importantly,
it turns out that that's the right thing
to do.
Because if a tragedy strikes in your
vicinity,
you know,
you can either lay down and fall victim
to it and then add to the problem or you
know,
you can stand up and take it and deal
with it and you know,
maybe be a comfort to the other people
around you that are also suffering the
tragedy and you can move forward.
You know,
and I saw this,
I'll start with this and then we can
take a break.
I had a client at one point who was
afraid of very many things.
For example,
she was a vegetarian and part of that
was because she was terrified of meat.
So she wouldn't go into a supermarket
where the butcher shop rows are.
And you know,
you can understand that.
It's like,
well,
how can you do that?
It's,
there's nothing but may Hammond carnage
there,
you know,
and you don't see it.
But she saw it,
you know?
And so it terrified her.
And so I take her to butcher shops now
and then get her kind of used to it.
And,
and she had a dream at one point,
and I can't remember the exact nature of
the dream,
but it was something like this.
She saw a gypsy in the forest and the
Gypsy said to her that unless she
learned how to work in a slaughter
house,
she'd never finished her degree because
she had been doing her degree forever
and she spent like 20 hours a day
sleeping.
So cause she didn't want to be conscious
because it was too burdensome.
So we talked about that dream.
She was quite a remarkable dreamer.
And I said,
well,
you better think about that.
Like you,
you need to do something that would push
you beyond your limits.
It's like you've not going to go to a
slaughter house because I don't think I
can arrange that,
but maybe you better think about what
you could do.
And so she went away and she came back
the next week and she said,
I think I want to go see an embalming.
I thought,
oh well,
you know,
Ooh,
I didn't really expect that.
So I thought,
okay,
well that's fine.
I'll,
so I called up a few funeral parlors and
um,
I told them what was going on and I
said,
you know,
is it possible that I could bring one of
my clients there?
And they said yes because they're kind
of used to deep like they deal with this
everyday,
right.
These people deal with that every day.
Mazing and so,
you know,
I took her there and it was quite an
exposure experience for me too.
You know,
cause I'd never seen anything like that.
And I'm a little bit on the squeamish
side or maybe even a lot on the screen
we side.
So you know,
we were in there and there was the
embalming table and the body was laid
out on the table and you know,
they were doing the prep work that they
have to do in order to preserve the body
for,
for the funeral in later.
And you know,
what's quite a gory process,
all things considered,
there's a lot of fluid drainage and that
kind of thing.
And so she was standing beside me,
we were outside the room,
it was a small room.
And so we were outside looking through
the door and she was basically doing
this.
And you know,
as she did that she'd look longer and
longer,
you know?
And then finally I would say after about
20 minutes,
she didn't run away.
After about 20 minutes,
she could just watch and then she asked
if she could go inside the room and you
know,
the guy you said that was fine.
And then she asked if she could touch
the body and like she did all of that,
you know?
And I learned a lot that day too because
I talked to them about how funerals are
arranged and all that sort of thing,
which is knowledge you need to know even
though it's terrible knowledge,
unless you want to be useless,
you need to know about that sort of
thing.
And you know what was really interesting
about that was after that she had some
calibration point for her fears,
you know,
so she thinks,
well I'm terrified at this,
therefore I can't.
Do people think that it's like,
well,
then she could think,
this is nowhere near as bad is like
going to the mortuary and watching
someone be embalmed.
So like,
I did that,
I can do this.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
Absolutely.
You know,
you have to be a monster to stay alive.
You,
it's better to be conscious monster
though,
then an unconscious monster because then
you know,
you're in control of the monster rather
than the other way around.
And it's necessary.
And part of what this book says is,
look,
you know,
if you pay attention to terrible things,
you can shrink them to manageable size.
They'll never go away,
but maybe you don't even want them to go
away,
but at least they'll shrink to
manageable size.
And that,
and what that tells you is just how
bloody powerful it is to pay attention.
So there's nothing more powerful than
paying attention.
Okay,
so let's take a break for a bit.
15 minutes.